hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to be
talking about
sbar specifically for nurse to physician
communication
so let's get started esbar is a
communication method that we can use to
help us simplify communicating
patient information to other members of
the healthcare team
and esbar is actually an acronym and it
stands for
situation background assessment and
recommendation
and the whole goal of the s bar is to
help us
strategically and systematically
communicate
like a patient situation along with the
background of that patient
the assessment findings that we have
found and recommendations that we
recommend
to that listener so they can easily
understand what we need
what we want and what is actually going
on with that patient in a very clear
and focused way so the esbar method can
help the nurse
stay organized whenever they're having
to communicate
and cut out that fluff that may be in
the conversation that wastes time or may
confuse the listener
and just help prevent those moments
where you may get
questions from the person you're talking
to and you may not know
you know that whole dreaded like uh i
don't know let me check
so the s bar is going to help you stay
organized
now what are some examples of how the
nurse would use the s
bar to communicate well one way would be
whenever a nurse needs to communicate
with a health care provider like a
physician
a nurse practitioner or a pa let's say
the patient's condition is deteriorating
and they need to call and report that
or they simply just need something for
that patient the nurse can follow this
tool which will help them clearly and
concisely communicate
that issue to the listener and that's
what we're going to be concentrating on
in this video how a nurse would
communicate specifically let's say with
a physician
about a patient issue and i'm going to
walk you through how you would apply
that
with the s bar now you can also use the
s bar as a nurse to communicate with
other nurses like during
report where we hand off the patient or
transferring a patient to a different
unit also it can be used with other
members of the healthcare team like
speech therapy occupational therapy
physical therapy
it just helps and guides you with what
information you need to provide to that
person so they can understand
what is going on with your patient so
whenever you're creating your s
bar in order to communicate with someone
you want to make sure that you are
fully prepared before you actually
initiate
that conversation so whenever you're new
to this
you really want to make sure you have
like a little system of how
you compile your s bar and over time
it's going to get really quick and you
can probably do a lot of this in your
head or just jot down and make notes
so the first thing what you want to do
is you want to get a layout of an
s bar a lot of units will have these
created for you and you just
fill them in and just put all the
information you need
whenever you're going to call that
person or talk to that person
also you want to make sure you have
thoroughly reviewed
that patient's chart and you know what's
going on with that patient so you
physically have went in there
looked at that patient assess that
patient you've collected their
vital signs and you've looked in the
chart you've looked at the latest
progress snow
and know who's on board taking care of
that patient
so you have an idea of what is going on
with that patient for when those
questions come up plus you have looked
at the latest lab results
you know what medications they're taking
because those questions will probably
come up and you'll definitely want to
include that in your sbar
if it's important for why you're calling
this person and then whenever you have
gathered all of that
information and you're comfortable and
ready to initiate that conversation
you want to make sure that you have all
of that stuff within reach
so have your computer on on that
specific patient so you can easily
look at something in case the person
asks you a question
and have your papers in front of you so
you can get to that information quickly
now let's talk about the information
that is included in each of these
sections of the s
bar and remember the s bar again is very
focused and concise with its
communication and remember there's no
fluff
in it so the first thing you're going to
start out with whenever you're
communicating using the s bar method
is with the situation so with the
situation
just as it says our whole goal is we're
going to communicate
why we are calling that's our purpose so
to help start things off
it's good to have a little introduction
by saying hello to whoever you're
calling if you're calling the physician
say hello doctor
whatever that person's name is or hello
to the nurse practitioner or the pa
and then identify yourself and the unit
that you're on so they can be familiar
with
okay this is the cardiac pcu or this is
the
cardiac icu that's who's calling me
and then state the patient's name who
you're calling about
and the room number and then a short
sentence for
why you are calling then after that
we're going to go straight into the
patient's
background and this part of the
communication
is again going to be very focused and
what its goal is going to do is it's
going to paint
a picture for that listener for while
we're calling so it's going to provide a
brief description on what has occurred
with that patient
up to this current situation and how you
would transition
from situation to background is you can
go into the patient's
diagnosis so the patient was admitted
with whatever diagnosis
on such and such day the date of
admission and then you're going to
tailor and include important patient
information
based on why you're calling so it can
really vary but here are some things
that you can include you can include the
patient's code status
you can talk about any other significant
health problems that goes along with the
patient's current situation
so if they're having cardiac problems
talk about some of their health history
with cardiac
issues like have they had heart caths
what were the results of that
have they had a history of certain
rhythms et cetera
then talk about medications if you need
to
fluids they have running any allergies
because that will tell them okay i can't
prescribe this because they're allergic
to this
and give them any test results you can
include blood work you can include any
procedures what the results of those
procedures were
and then if you are reporting blood work
let's say you're calling about an h you
want to make sure you're looking at the
previous
h h's and see how are they trending have
they been
gradually going down and now we're
critically low so know
how that is going and along with
consults what other doctor groups
are on board with this patient and any
pending procedures that the patient may
be having as well that just lets them
know okay i don't need to order this
because they're going to be having this
procedure
so at the end of this video we're going
to be going over
a scenario and you're going to see how
you
tailor this background section whenever
you are communicating a patient's
history
the next one is communicated is the
assessment part
and this is where the nurse is going to
tell the listener
what they have assessed so what they
have found in that patient
and what they think is going on based on
what they have found
so the nurse will explain you know
i think that this is possibly a
respiratory issue cardiac issue
gisu etc and then provide those
assessment findings and current vital
signs to back
up their what they think is going on
but let's say that the nurse doesn't
know they know that something's wrong
with the patient they know the patient
needs something
but they don't know exactly what it is
well it's okay the nurse can just say
that they are worried
or that the patient is deteriorating
they're unstable and they have changed
from when they previously saw them
and then lastly we're going to wrap up
the conversation with
recommendations so this is the part
where you're going to communicate to the
listener what you specifically want or
need
for that patient so you've laid the
framework for everything with your
assessment background and situation
while you're calling
and this is where you specifically
communicate
what you need or what you need done for
this patient
so this can really be anything it can be
you want more orders for the patient
let's say
that they need some more lab work you
think you can ask for that or
testing or you need a clarification on
something maybe a medication order
didn't seem quite right you need some
more clarification on it
or you need them to see the patient or
transfer the patient
to receive a higher level of care
or let's say you don't know what to ask
for
you can ask them for what they recommend
or
what they want you to do based on
everything you have told them
now let's go over an example with how a
nurse would use the esbar method to
communicate with a physician
about a patient that was just admitted
and they're starting to deteriorate
so we have this patient who was admitted
to your cardiac pcu
floor and they have a diagnosis of
cardiomyopathy
and about mid-noon the patient started
having extreme difficulty
breathing and their blood pressure has
become elevated
and you look through the patient's
medications you don't really have
anything that could help you decrease
that blood pressure
or help with the respiratory status of
the patient
so you're notifying the physician to let
them know that the patient's status has
changed and you need further medication
orders or a change in their medications
and further testing to investigate what
is going on
with this patient so you have compiled
all the information you need to make
this phone call
and you're ready to call them so now the
physician has
called you back and this is how you're
going to start the conversation you're
going to start with the s
part the situation so you're going to
say hello dr ross this is sarah from
1800 the cardiac pcu floor
i'm taking care of mr morris in room
1802
and i'm concerned about the patient's
recent development
of dysmia and hypertension then you're
going to flip
into the background part and paint that
picture
for dr ross for why you're really
calling what's going on with this
patient up to this point
he was admitted early this morning and
has a diagnosis of cardiomyopathy
he has a history of coronary artery
disease hypertension
and aortic valve disease the medications
he's currently ordered
are lisinopril 10 milligrams po daily
and furosemide 20 milligrams pobid
then you want to go into the assessment
part what you have
found and what you think is going on
with the patient
so he's developed crackles throughout
his lung fields especially in the right
and left lower lobes his oxygen
saturation has dropped from 95 percent
to 87 percent onto leader's nasal
cannula
and his respiratory rate is 28 and when
he speaks or performs any type of
physical exertion he becomes extremely
short of breath
also he has three plus pitting edema in
his lower extremities and a current
blood pressure of 200 over 120 and his
heart rate is 102
it's regular sinus tac i think he's
experiencing
fluid volume overload which may be
contributing to
his respiratory status and current
cardiac
issues and then lastly you want to wrap
up the conversation
with what you recommend or what you want
to see done with the patient
so i think the patient may need an
adjustment in medications and further
diagnostic testing
how would you like me to proceed with
this patient do you want me to order a
change in medications
or diagnostic testing like a chest x-ray
abg's
cardiac series echo to further
investigate the patient's condition
and then whenever you are done with that
you want to listen to the provider
and if they give you any orders or
anything like that you want to read back
that information to make sure that you
have correctly
understood what they have said and then
whenever you get off the phone you want
to be sure that you complete whatever
orders you were given and document okay
so that wraps up this video
over the s bar and if you would like to
watch more videos in this series you can
access the videos in the youtube
description
below